[Musique]
on attend une politique de sécurité
on n'attend pas que le président de la
république fasse des phrases on attend
qu'ils agissent
or aujourd'hui d'actions il n'en a pas
eu depuis deux ans et demi rien n'a été
fait il a reporté ce discours combien de
fois la première fois qu'il en a parlé
c'est en janvier 2018 puis en juin 2018
puis en janvier 2019
et tout ça pour arriver à dire est-ce
que c'est du communautarisme ou est-ce
que c'est du séparatisme
mais de qui se moque t-on que le brésil
en mettre quasiment trois ans pour se
réveiller sur le sujet c'est un bois
samoa préoccupant
la france est le premier pourvoyeur
angie à 10 la france connaît une
situation de communautarisation dans
notre pays qui est gravissime
les nuits c'est pas seulement le
séparatisme c'est pas seulement le
communautarisme
les nuits c'est l'islamisme oui il nous
faut lutter contre l'islamisme politique
est radical parce que quand il veut
imposer une idéologie aux autres les
lois de la république s'impose partout
et pour tous on ne doit plus céder face
à l'islam politique et la laïcité ne
doit plus être négocié
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
personne aujourd'hui une réponse pour
soi même en disant voilà à peu près
comment je pourrai prendre ma retraite
c'est donc une inquiétude absolue est
pour et pour tout le monde
le gouvernement minutieusement depuis le
début qui comme je pense ils ont voulu
jouer les gros bras en expliquant qu' il
arriverait à tout faire contre les
autres qu'ils avaient raison contre tout
le monde qu'il n'écouterait personnes et
que si on n'était pas content c'était
pareil on se taisait
et bien quand on arrive au bout du
cheminement qui le débat parlementaire
est naturellement la démocratie reprend
le dessus et le projet qui nous est
proposée par la majorité n'est pas le
bon il n'est pas le bon parce que il
n'est pas financé
on a fait le choix de la responsabilité
nous sommes un parti de gouvernement et
donc en tant que parti gouvernement nous
avons présenté un contre-projet la seule
façon de peser sur le financement celle
c'est une mesure d'âge une vraie mesure
d'âge
[Musique]